so you know that what happened at the
capitol is not just bad
which we all agree not just condemnable
which we all agree on
it's the worst thing that's ever
happened in the history of america much
worse than pearl harbor
and it was only only right wingers there
were no left-wingers that were involved
at all
they did happen to arrest a blm activist
who was there but forget about that and
he was on cnn but no that's not a big
not a big deal
but actually it is the case i think they
were mostly right-wingers right
uh and very bad thing
but we did just have a whole year of
political violence from the left didn't
we we did just have a whole year of blm
burning down city after city after city
torching businesses killing dozens of
people
we did just have antifa a radical left
organization
set up a sort of sovereign city
right a city state called the chaz the
capitol hill
authorized zone is that was that or
independent zone or such
that would be chis i guess who knows it
was this radical
left-wing social experiment that was
tolerated it was perfectly tolerated
for quite a long time a lot of this
stuff
has come out of portland ted wheeler
mayor of portland
has come out come under a lot of fire
because he has
tolerated and you might even say
encouraged
through his negligence and through his
ideological
declarations this kind of left-wing
violence that's plagued portland
and the surrounding areas so one
intrepid local news host
was interviewing mayor wheeler and said
you know yeah we all agree capitol hill
that thing's really bad but don't you
think uh
you're uh permitting this left-wing
violence to go on for so long don't you
think that might have had
i don't know something to do with it
three weeks ago protesters broke into
the oregon state capitol i have heard
people at these protests elsewhere
saying well they let it happen in
portland so why not do it here
it seems in some way the actions of
these small groups that you're referring
to
have set the stage for what has happened
on a state level and potentially a
national level i know you said
it will take time to crack down on these
groups but do we have that time
are you blaming me for what happened at
the u.s capitol
are you wait a minute are you are you
saying that because i've uh permitted
and one might even say encourage the
violence
from the left here and that the left
broadly has has encouraged violence for
months and months and months and burned
down sea to shining sea
are you saying that might have something
to do with the
mostly right-wing violence that took
place for a few hours at the capitol
that is what we're saying i'm glad that
you are hearing what we're saying
because for a week now the left has
deflected and they've said no that's
what a baptism
no it's only right-wing violence no it's
completely different no it's not
it's not it's not it's bad to like
go attack the capital for a few hours
that is bad
it's much much worse to burn the country
down for several months
it's bad to go in and disrupt the
offices of
members of congress it's worse to
destroy many many many many many
business owners livelihoods and
buildings and property
and lives in some cases that is what
we're talking about
we are blaming you ted wheeler
and we're blaming you maxine waters who
called for violence and we're blaming
you
chris cuomo who defended political
violence
and we're blaming you hillary clinton
who said you can't be civil with your
opponents
and we're blaming all of you guys you
did this
donald trump didn't do this donald trump
didn't do this
at all some trump supporters
did some political violence
for a few hours at the capitol that was
bad
after months and months and months of
what
you did if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you